c'est l'information du jour pour tous
les marseillais et tous les amateurs de
football sa décision est prise il la
livrera ce soir zinedine zidane dira si
oui ou non il quitte l'équipe de france
de football
plusieurs sources sont formelles zizou
devrait mettre un terme à sa carrière
internationale fin d'une aventure avec
les bleus
au terme de 93 sélections et 63
victoires à marseille le quartier qui
l'a vu naître cette décision en a
surpris plus d'un la castellane ne veut
pas voir partir son héros reportage
francis mazoyer et benoît jourdain
beaucoup d'émotion ce matin à la
castellane zidane qui met un terme à sa
carrière en bleu
on refuse d'y croire dans cette cité des
quartiers nord de marseille jo d'athènes
zidane l'un des cousins de zizou l'a
appris par la presse
j'ai eu à le journal est ce ma choqué il
a tout donné pour la france nous a
ramené la coupe du monde tout ça est
maintenant safer droit depuis l'enfance
l'enfant de la castellane brandissant la
coupe du monde 98
une immense fierté ici personne n'en
doute c'est le meilleur joueur du monde
qui devrait tirer sa révérence
ronaldinho et kaka en place pour lui
qu'on regarde de la france à la casse et
monique de france au real par marc est
incroyable
du rêve voilà ce que le football apporte
à ces jeunes de cette cité défavorisée
où le taux de chômage dépasse les 50%
il a eu le fierté et l'honneur de
pouvoir accueillir 1 88 ça fait qu'ils
aient souvenirs qui tu parle beaucoup du
rêve mais aussi un exemple avec zizou
c'est une réussite pour plein de jeunes
pour plein de personnes pas que soit
catane sur le sur la france entière et
sur le monde entier va nous accueillons
terminer monsieur voulait à la taille
des gardiens bol ça soit arrivé là avec
mes bras ça fait ça donc j'ai toujours
un espace pour passer le ballon comme il
avait une frappe déjà assez
impressionnante
ça fait six ans une retraite chez les
bleus cet ancien dirigeant de septèmes
qui a entraîné zidane en minimes n'est
pas surpris ces chenilles qui a duré dix
ans et que non il se sent peut-être une
vraie manne sonné par cette génération
là quoi donc
il ya plein de terre il a créé ne se
retrouve un peu seul et de peintres
reconnus comme il devrait l'être
pagenaud vague qui arrive il reste
maintenant à lui trouver un successeur à
la castellane certains sont peut-être
déjà sur les rangs